look at this shaq randomly played for a
young man's engagement ring
he put some money down but i was like
you know what tell your girlfriend i
gotta take care of it i'm into making
people happy so whenever i leave the
house i just try to do
a good deed oh shaq we knew you were a
big man
you're in trouble and the nba legend has
once again proved he's also got that big
heart
shaquille o'neal was in a jewelry store
in the atlanta area on monday
which is when his good deed was caught
on camera
every time you come in here i always get
on 30 minutes before you come in here
in this video that has since gone viral
the former laker sneakily takes out his
credit card and
offers to pay for a stranger's
engagement ring
i went in to get some loop bearings and
i seen a guy come in he was just so shy
he was saying hey how much do i owe to
pay off my rent it was just
and i was like how much is the ring the
two shook
hands and later posed for this photo
together
you went to the mall and went to zelle
wait what you going
to want me to go to piedmont park you're
going to sales first of all on tuesday
shaq appeared on tnt's nba
after show and opened up about why he
wanted to help the stranger put a ring
on it
the guy just came in and you know he's a
hard young kid he's a hard-working guy
he's like hey man i can come back next
month and then like you
lay away like yeah he put some money
down but i was like you know what tell
your girlfriend i gotta
take care of it at first he didn't want
to take it he said no i can't do that i
said don't worry about it
shaq said he had no intention of
publicizing his moment of kindness
but he did admit that acts like these
have become part of his daily life
i'm into making people happy so whenever
i leave the house i just try to do it
a good deed like i didn't mean for that
to get out because i don't do it for
that but this is something that i do
every day
the other day me and my mom went
furniture shopping and this lady uh
she had a autistic daughter
and you know she was also you know
looking to pay for some furniture i just
i just took care of it and we can't say
shaq's generous spirit is a surprise
that in march he told et about his
mission to help people get back
on track following the pandemic
shaquille you have a birthday coming up
what are you going to do how are you
going to celebrate
what i want for my birthday actually i
don't want to make my
i'm blessed six wonderful children
mother sister brother live around the
corner from me
everything i've wanted to do that's come
true so
i can't be even happier so you know that
gift's not gonna make me
i'm talking to one of the most talented
females in the business right now
i'm happy yeah you know i live on a 30
acre farm in
downtown georgia i'm happy so i don't
want anything
you know there's a lot more people that
are struggling than me more than i do i
know i'm i'm fortunate enough to you
know do everything
that i want that's because i listen to
my parents not because i'm the smartest
guy in the world just
mom and dad say hey do this say this act
like this you can accomplish anything
you want so
my my wish for my birthday is that you
know
those people get back on track
you